how's the girl Beth my name's Pierre
welcome to another oculus rift game I
don't know much about this one the
developer has been very clear not to
cheat or like look look up anything in
advance so if you both plan on playing
this game yourself you might not want to
watch the video you probably don't have
an oculus anyway anyway let's do it
that looks so real it's so weird look at
that belly
oh yeah the jiggly belly I like it
whoa all right so I'm in my flat
whoa look at the moves pretty sure this
is not how legs work but who knows dude
I know it this probably looks stupid as
hell on YouTube but it looks real that
is real most pillows real on it says
kill Justin Bieber no Jacob Kissel
that's cool all right let's go outside
ow what am I going damn but what is
going on hey
what um I have a girlfriend what da [ __ ]
bros who a said girl hello
what the [ __ ] are you what what are you
doing what are you doing huh is that an
iPad what are you doing
stop playing Angry Birds what is this ah
don't trust her make her nervous but
stay away I knew I couldn't trust her
alright it's pretty sweet setup can I go
out how do I make you nervous
but if I pee in the sink that you go to
something like that not that I would
know ah oh my god is my favorite movie
Braveheart
that's Skyrim it is guy okay
no is it I don't know I can't see it's
like Oh Haley swagalicious look at them
Danes oh that is his weird
oh dude are you okay
bro brow yeah what's going on put on
some socks man whoa whoa shut up
fawful say man Wow whoa whoa what what
what what the [ __ ] I know it she's a
cyborg what kill her I got to kill her
oh [ __ ] I'm out of here [ __ ] this I know
the stitches weren't real don't look at
me like that girl don't you dare look at
me like that do you see how so I know I
look good but I mean hi [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
hey that's whose boss my test what is
wrong with you you made me do it
she made me do it I did not have
anything to do with that [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] see that's what happens when
they're on their period
all right the second one is called [ __ ]
I mean breach it's actually made by a
couple of guys who went to the same
university as me Chalmer that's pretty
cool all right let's get in whoa
I have to say like games that are Doric
just feels more real because it you
don't think about the mask around your
eyes or whatever ha ha whoa what oh okay
that's cool
oh yeah the story is like I'm waking up
from cryosleep or whatever and something
[ __ ] weird happen it's like no [ __ ]
hello I would like to go back to sleep
now what is this place by my all alone
hello
whoa what do you want door hey shut up
you don't know me I don't know that the
like of the deal simply whoa shut up
door you scare my tits off I bet
Slenderman did something
whoa slide open so nice all right
creepy corridor no big deal I've been in
plenty creeper kook
what is that over there yeah I just
walked in circles up and play sesame up
no [ __ ] way this is so creepy like I am
having goose bumps I don't think you can
see it but whatever am I supposed to do
II maybe I can hide in here oh I don't
like I don't like that ambience and
beyond that sounds like dr. Ambrose
ah ah you're so slow hi oh wow well this
is nice and spacious I like this play
what what was that door moving huh okay
that was a fun game that's a great game
all right let's finish up with something
nice and that won't scare my pets off
huh I scream so loud like I I don't
think my throat has ever hurt that much
afterwards yeah it's like I have a penis
on my nose this is amazing
are you doing what's going on I'm whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoops sorry
timing is the mecca thing all that
football I got a [ __ ] [ __ ] it back
yes
what are you going we're going Hadouken
should start working my snabel is not
total [ __ ] haha oh sorry this is amazing
alright hey yeah sorry about that
[ __ ] Ellen oh nice elephant slap whoa
I'd say that's a score this is how I
imagined drugs would be like at least
who needs drugs when you have it oculus
rift whoa damn Louis ah why they always
got to do that what what aliens really
know what is coping on whoa seriously
inception real whoa what is going on I
may be an elephant but I have Felix
like that this is a normal day hi-oh
with it stop attacking me [ __ ] off
BAM hey what are you doing
come on bugger off will ya bah
goddamn cops [ __ ] the pudding pop oh I'm
an elephant ain't nobody stopping me
that's right [ __ ] ain't no stopping
when PT personnel it poppin all right
well I can fly it [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] yes best game ever cannot it oh
isn't it the helicopter it's working
it's working
no it's working just working thanks for
playing
press any key takeaway it's still scared
me all right that's all the oculus rift
for today hope people enjoy watching
leave a like if you did let me know if
you want more and subscribe come breath
today I'll see you in the next one
stay awesome love you yes Oh what nice
toys